bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france comment accueillez
vous cette décision d'étendre le passé
ni terre à certains centres commerciaux
est ce que certaines de vos boutiques
sont concernés
bonjour c'est encore une mauvaise
nouvelle pour nous les centres
commerciaux on est assez durement touché
depuis le début de cette crise je vous
rappelle qu'on est à terme est de quatre
mois le cet hiver on a fermé le 31
janvier pour ouvrir fin mai et une
nouvelle fois les commerciaux sont
frappées de restriction forte lourde
aujourd'hui moi je suis plutôt dans le
nord-ouest où je suis pas touché à
l'immédiat mais il ya fort à parier que
dans les prochains jours les prochaines
semaines tous les sites commerciaux tous
les grands centres commerciaux de france
seront concernés on n'est le cas que les
dix hommes des couvre-feux qui
concernait quelques départements dans un
premier temps et très vite toute la
france étaient touchées et il ya de
grandes chances pour qu'il en soit de
même pour les centres commerciaux
quelles sont vos craintes si jamais se
passe sanitaire est étendue à tous les
centres commerciaux en france que vous
ayez moins de clients peut-être
exactement vous voyez à titre d'exemple
c'est leur brouille tellement les doigts
au gouvernement que le préfet de
loire-atlantique a activé se passe à
lithaire dans un centre commercial à
nantes où où je gère un magasin alors
que l'indicateur n'était pas
n'hésitez pas l'application de ce passe
donc le passé été mis en place le pass
été retiré trois jours après le sacre
est une grosse confusion sur les
salariés sur l'organisation du centre
sur les clients et en l'espace de trois
jours simplement on a mesuré déjà
une affluence un trafic divisée par 3
vous vous rendez compte l'impact que ça
/ 3 donc si on a ces mesures-là qui il
semble bon durer dans le temps jusqu'à
juge jusqu'à libère minimum donc
aujourd'hui l'équation ne fonctionne pas
on peut pas nous d'y augmenter nos
charges de fonctionnement parce que le
contrôle du pass mais on va avoir un
coût qui n'est pas neutre et si on
parlait de sarlat diminution forte de
l'affluence et donc des recettes il y
aura des gros déséquilibre est
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui je suis assez
inquiet pour l'avenir de beaucoup de
commerces notamment commerciaux pour
vous le port du masque obligatoire et
est déjà suffisant pour protéger les
clients de potentielle contamination
bien sûr oui et vous parler de ce que je
connais également à son commerciaux ont
fait partie des sites où on prend
maximum de mesures
le port du masque de contrôler il ya des
bandes de chez vous les 20 et 50 mètres
et des parcours fléché distance à
respecter il ya des plexiglas on est
vraiment sur des sites où toutes les
mesures sont prises et un abêtissement
humains et matériels qui est fait depuis
de très longs mois donc à mon sens c'est
une vraie discrimination d'imposer ces
nouvelles restrictions aux centres
commerciaux où il ya aucun élément
factuel qui tente à prouver qu'ils sont
des commerciaux sont des lieux à risque
je ne comprends pas je ne comprends pas
je fais super encore des grosses
conséquences et là je pense que
maintenant tant qu'elle cision éprise
malheureusement va devoir s'y adapter
mais je pense qu'ils ont très vite des
indemnités qui soient mis en place parce
que en tant qu ciment de la fédération
nationale de l'habillement ou les
charges permanentes avec beaucoup de
commerçants et
il ya beaucoup de chose de très négatif
qui réduisent trop bien dans les
prochaines semaines des prochains mois
parce que l'activité économique est très
fragilisée par les commerçants des
centres commerciaux alors on a quand
même plus de la moitié de la population
qui est entièrement vaccinés qui a donc
son pass and iter est ce que vous
craignez tout de même que cela amenuise
votre au nombre de clients
tout à fait après je vais dire
l'équation est simple c'est que on a
moins de trafic on a moins de clients
donc au final sur le tiroir caisse pour
parler un peu plus schématiquement ça va
se ressentir on a fait le choix nous
remercions cessé dans les centres
commerciaux pour bénéficier de ce flux
de ce trafic cette affluence avec des
charges en conséquent des loyers est le
plus important des charges locatives
plus importante et aujourd'hui tout est
mis en place pour que nous commerçants
bénéficient pulsé flux et il y aurait
des répercussions énormes sur son
chiffre d'affaires et le llorach et des
clips qui qui va apparaître on a déjà
créé un équilibre pendant quatre mois
où le gouvernement n'a pas joué le jeu
et nous a mis en difficulté depuis
quatre mois les discussions continuent
venir auprès de l'analyser et monsieur
maisons neuves mais ils font la sourde
oreille mais on va continuer les alerter
l'année dernière on a déjà fermé trois
mois aujourd'hui la paix plein je pense
que nous on est on est les premiers à
vouloir lutter contre provident vouloir
faire le maximum de choses pour
accueillir nos clients dans les
meilleures dispositions pour leur faire
partager la meilleure expérience
possible mais pourquoi ils sont
commerciaux pourquoi en collection de
commerciaux pourquoi nous faire subir
autant dallaire
on a perdu la connexion avec vont en
tout cas on a on a bien compris est
votre point de vue sur le sujet merci
beaucoup maxime baca d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous gérez
des boutiques dans plusieurs centres
commerciaux en france merci à vous